what would our 2D friend do if they
encountered an obstacle without
knowledge of the third dimension they
wouldn't be able to go around they could
try to tunnel under leaving up support
Gates behind them to prevent a collapse
but it would be easier to just jump
right over after all if they are
infinitesimally thin then they should
weigh nothing at all and should be quite
proficient at jumping high if you look
closely you'll see she's actually
carrying a vaulting pole for this
precise purpose we could also help of
course by moving our friend through the
third dimension I can help her get to
places that she wouldn't be able to
access otherwise just remind me to move
her back shortly I'd hate for her to get
stuck there